the polls have been all over the map and
the numbers in specific polls have also
been all over the map but it is safe to
say that as of this week as many as 8
percent of Americans say they plan to
vote for Gary Johnson or Jill Stein for
president if you are one of them
especially if you are a millennial give
an old liberal 5 minutes to try to
explain to you why you should not I'm
not gonna try to sell you on Hillary
Clinton I am NOT going to invoke Ralph
Nader and 2000 I am NOT going to wax
nostalgic about nearly voting third
party in 1980 I am NOT going to linger
on how I want three or four major
parties what I am going to tell you is
that all of these points valid invalid
or somewhere in between cannot be the
priority this election not my priority
and not yours especially not when your
vote may decide whether it is Clinton or
Trump who becomes president this is
really simple if you vote for Gary
Johnson or you vote for Jill Stein you
need to assume that it will be the last
presidential vote you get to cast I'm
not being symbolic I'm not being
hyperbolic I am pointing out simple
realities in every swing state a vote
for Johnson or Stein is one less for
Hillary Clinton and her victory over
Donald Trump as big a victory by as
large and indisputable a margin as
possible is vital to your safety it is
necessary to make sure the country still
exists four years from now essential to
make sure your right to vote still
exists one year from now the difference
between Clinton and Trump is that stark
whatever is wrong with Donald Trump
emotionally or psychiatrically the
healthiest diagnosis would probably be
extreme anger management problems he has
asked why this country does not use its
nuclear weapons he has repeatedly talked
about putting his opponents in the
election in prison he gave a speech at
Gettysburg last Saturday at Gettysburg
Abraham Lincoln where he said that his
first 100 days as president would be
like this all about who would be
prosecuted and who he was going to sue
and which news organizations were
corrupt
three times he has refused to promise
that he will accept the election outcome
if he loses the one truly timelessly
eternally noble part of this very flawed
to
ah cracy of ours the peaceful transition
of power and he is deliberately leaving
doubt about it and couraging his
supporters to believe the election is or
may be rigged and even dog whistling
about how they should go to the polling
places in inner cities on Election Day
and act as a kind of vigilante group
against minority voters there the man is
a bigot he has shown no commitment to
free elections in this country he is a
bully with severe anger-management
problems combined with a desire to have
and use nuclear weapons and he's running
not for president but for dictator
Hillary Clinton strengths weaknesses our
first woman president all of it and all
of it nearly secondary to the fact that
she is sane and she believes in our form
of democracy it's that simple you vote
for Stein or Johnson and it is one less
vote for Clinton but it's also one less
vote that Trump has to match because of
how this election will play out in the
swing states your vote for Stein or
Johnson might as well be a vote for
Trump it will have the same effect I
read not long ago to pieces at Vox buy a
pair of 21 year old voters one for
Johnson one for Stein one part of each
piece twin mirror images of dissent
jumped out at me this is from the Stein
voter his name is Sean Shaw Sal a
student at Simpson College in Iowa his
vote he writes is a deliberate stand
against the two-party system and this is
from the Johnson voter Stephanie Paige
was at Ohio State I understand that
Johnson has little to no chance of
becoming president but I need to use my
voice to tell our government that we
need to change the way things are done
we need to change the way things are
done no argument here
my generation failed at it you are
getting your chance a deliberate stand
against the two-party system amen and in
any other election Bush Gore or Obama
McCain or if this one had been Bush
Clinton I would say enjoy but there is
an assumption in both these statements
we need to change the way things are
done a deliberate stand against the
two-party system why do you assume that
if you get rid of the two-party system
the only option then is a three-party
system or four or five what if it
one what have you get your wish change
the way things are done
no more two-party system and you instead
get a one-party system what if you vote
Johnson or Stein and Trump gets elected
what about this Trump guy suggests that
he cares about what happens after he is
elected why are you so sure that even
this democracy can withstand a crazy man
with the authoritarian style of a 1930s
dictator and a campaign undertone of
putting his opponent in prison what
makes you think he is not going to put
his opponent in prison or put his other
opponents in prison or the media in
prison or Muslims or next the LGBTQ
community who knows or put you in prison
people tell me to compromise and vote
for the lesser of two evils the Stein
voter mr. Shah saw also wrote but I
cannot compromise when it comes to my
beliefs especially when they involve
human rights and systemic oppression the
point this year is not are you
compromising your beliefs the point this
year is that you could wind up electing
a president who will compromise your
beliefs for you and who will make your
complaints now about human rights or
oppression or the two-party system look
to you in retrospect like a quick dance
in the spring rain you want to change
our system please do my generation did
fail if you fail on November 8th and
Trump gets elected
nobody's gonna pull you or me out of it
change all this at the midterms do it in
the state legislatures do it in 2020 the
guy who wants to change all this right
now who you may help to become president
has no interest in human rights
especially not yours you want more he
wants less although I'm certain systemic
oppression sounds pretty good to him if
you want to vote for Trump I can't stop
you nobody can just remember though if
you are voting for Jill Stein or Gary
Johnson you are also voting for this man
Trump
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space